the director of dumb and Dumberer
kingpin something about marry me myself
and Irene Shallow Hal and more peter
farrelly the director of Loudermilk
coming to audience coming up next
Tuesday October 17th right here on the
Rich Eisen show good to see you rich
thanks from you thanks for having back I
love it you were here and just one of
the first couple weeks or show you and
Bobbie your brother who we surprised you
with Brett yeah with the retreat who you
had not seen since Something About Mary
right yes we you know it's funny you
hardly see anybody when you do a movie
where it's like you're you know carnies
you go off everybody goes in separate
directions I probably see Cameron Diaz
three times since that movie is that
right and by the way she also lives in
my hometown and the town I'm in she's in
Ojai
so you haven't even run in to hear about
her all the time
how about Ben Stiller have you seen him
I've seen Ben a little more because I
was good friends with his mom and dad
and I actually was in better touch yeah
I was in touch with them and I'd bump
into a band hanging with the you know
parents right and now you and I first
met years and years and years ago I was
still on SportsCenter we've met at the
Brad Faxon Billy had charity golf
tournament Rhode Island yeah those guys
are Island guys exactly and how did you
ever get fixed up with well we just
renowned a small place as you might know
and so everybody knows everybody and I
knew those guys but I remember in fact I
was just putting on your putting green
over here beforehand and I remember Brad
you know Brad was he was always the best
putter on tour I think for ten years in
a rose in the top five putters on tour
and one day I asked him I said so what's
the key did it like these you know five
foot and less what's the thing he says
just don't give it I said yeah but
seriously but seriously was he goes
that's that's it just don't give you
like how could you not give a guys you
just don't because I know I'm gonna miss
some every now and then I don't give it
but the problem is is you can't turn
your brain off like that you'd only
right and he just doesn't care he does
just end that so those that's it don't
care if you care it's gonna be hard but
why isn't that work for Jay Cutler
because yeah you know I mean it what
works for Faxon is not worked for Jay
Cutler to this bullets like this if I if
I had okay say I had a thing
that wide okay that went across this
room of five feet wide it's like this no
like this two and a half feet saying and
I had to walk across that room right on
that that's a breeze and anybody could
do it yes
put that up a half a mile high and it's
that wide I probably fall off cuz you
care and that's what he does he just
doesn't care he just doesn't care and
and then it's it's always gonna be maple
how is your golf game Peter not good not
good I'm I'm an 18 but I'm like an
easily blow over a hundred or if I have
a really nice round I'm like 88 89 seem
it for me on the same exact way and I
just wish I cared enough just to use
this analogy to continue it on I mean
I'd love to but trust me I would love to
be one of those guys that she's 72 73
good day maybe I'm in the sixth yeah I
don't know I don't think I've got the
mental capacity for that I never yeah
I'm the exact same thing I like I'll be
on a golf course and I'll hit a shot and
I think I know exactly what I did wrong
there and I'll be walking to my next
shot and in between they're all I'm
thinking about is my old girlfriend from
high school what I had for dinner last
night where we going tonight the
restaurant is my dog I take him to vet I
get into the shot like what was that
again I was trying I don't focus on the
game I'm terrible about that
and that's why I've never been good it's
it's it's and also I don't like hitting
balls hitting balls it makes me sore I'm
the same way
for friends of my baby yet so we're
gonna will tee off around like 11
o'clock so show up around 9:30 yeah I'll
get something to drink or heat and then
you know and then and then we'll hit
some balls yeah no I don't it hurts to
hit balls people but also you feel like
whoa wait a second I might hit all the
good shots on the range yeah you know
maybe I should hold off and save them
same for the game I don't want to waste
them out there yeah I hate hitting balls
but my all the guys I play with you
they're there 45 minutes and I were
really hitting a bang no I'm not I just
can't do it
peter farrelly director of Loudermilk
come in an audience network next week
and of course some of the funnier
comedies in recent past joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show so you're just
really laid back
dude okay where's the anger in your
sports fandom because normally every red
sock patriot bruins Celtic man has to be
angry when they win at somebody or
something are you
I never got that I never understood that
I'm not angry like that well even when
we lost and I grew up we always lost red
socks always lost Patriots always lost
yes
you know we had won in 15 seasons with
the Pats um I grew up 15 minutes from
Foxborough I was at all those games and
it was painful but I never had I never
had anger in fact I don't even have
anger towards I never had anger towards
a Yankees like you know people who hate
the Yankees I think I like the Yankees
or our rivals I mean there's something
about him I like like I never hated like
I first of all they're not like Bernie
Williams and guys like this they're
likeable I didn't hate those guys I
didn't want them to win but I have no no
animosity toward him I just want us to
beat them Brockman is this the only red
sock Patriot guy that you've ever met
that's yeah well he's a very
level-headed man have you watched the
show yesterday I'm not a level-headed
yes you couldn't have understood what
everybody he's here on like you know
[Laughter]
they've made a little too much like you
hit the guys glove out of the way it's
like you know we did that the Bronson
Arana Rio yeah I mean you know I just
thought yeah you know I didn't bug me
and then Jeter of course you love Jeter
Maury I love Joe Torre when he was the
manager and I liked I even liked Jason
Giambi because he was the only only
steroid guy who admitted it only guy who
admitted he came right out to you I used
steroids I did it I shouldn't know Peter
if only more could be admired the guy he
still do admire what about Roger Goodell
do you have a problem I don't like
Rogers I don't like authority figures
like that just in general wow that's too
much like he's he's like he's this kind
of like ice make the rules you just got
to pay like it is no I listen I have a
right to your day in court and he
doesn't give you that that's what pisses
me off but him Peter Farrelly
on the Rich Eisen show and just - I
guess circle back Faxon and Andrade the
professional golfers who were in the
opening scene of King tonight in the
disco bowling scene right there yeah you
got those cameos going yeah yeah they
they know we had we always you know
we're sports fans we grew up sports fans
and so when we started making movies it
was an opportunity to meet some the
first one we did of course we put Cam
Neely in there we knew Kansas right cam
was friends with Woody Harrelson was my
roommate when I moved to LA in the
eighties no way yeah and he was good
friends with and then he got on cheers
and he was friends with Michael J Fox
who was friends with Cam Neely they'd
played hockey together growing up so we
started hanging around with this so when
we made the movie I said hey we should
put cam in there because he'd be a good
character actor and then from that point
on we just said hey this fund so we've
called our you know the guys Tom Brady
was in one with Lawrence with a lawyer
Milloy and Brett Favre you know our
favorites might the guy I never worked
with who I just think is not just like
obviously you know unbelievable athlete
but maybe one of the best academic I've
ever seen Peyton Manning I'm telling you
he could win an Oscar I'm not kidding
you he's not just okay he is as good as
most actors I work with he in the right
role that guy could win an act an Oscar
and that's the God's honest truth he's
Knightley he is that good he's never had
a bad commercial I would agree with you
on that front
yeah he's he and he makes it he makes it
just little tiny things he just finds
these little things cuz he's not afraid
to commit
he's not afraid like they get
embarrassed that's what happens actors
getting embarrassed there don't want to
make a fool of themselves but he doesn't
care and that makes him a great actor I
would agree with you I've said the the
Saturday Night Live skit where they did
the fake United Way commercial he's Wiz
in the balls at the kids oh yeah
whatever he tells a great story about
how the parents you know we're watching
on the sidelines and they're they're
like you know he was concerned oh yeah
the kid the parents of the kid actors he
was concerned about and they were like
just don't go for it I always thought he
and Owen Wilson
to do a movie together because they're
very similar if you listen to their
their cadence it's a very kind of like
you know we're in the history of our
relationship do you think like he's got
that same kind of like vibe and those
two is like buddies or somewhere that
would be that'd be a great movie and he
could pull it off let's do it let's do
it I mean your hands full with let's
yeah all right let's let's let's spit
ball on this and speaking of Loudermilk
again that starts on audience speaking
day October 17th 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time
starring Ron Livingston playing a
recovering alcoholic substance abuse
counselor who's got a little bit awfully
bad he's an ex rock and roll critic who
was on tour with rock bands for 20 years
and he went off the rails got into drugs
alcohol everything like the poor guy in
Miami this yeah the offense and and and
and he's now cleaning it up and trying
to get his crap together and but he's
he's a little angry about everything but
it's not it doesn't take place in a
12-step meeting but you meet the people
in it and you go on and you follow them
and it's it's a it's a comedy but it's
definitely got some some you know a
little more than that well Ron
Livingston is perfect for that
phenomenal I mean he really can do the
serious
yeah and then the comedy office space is
one of my favorite movies advice what
what do you think of office space
classic in fact you know I was Mike
judge is well you know my judge is a you
know national treasure and I thought
office space was just a masterpiece and
then when idiocracy came out I was there
Friday night opening weekend went to
that thing my wife and I were there and
I remember thinking this is a one of the
great movies of all time and it will do
zero business because it's so ah but now
it's like come true you know he's he's
prescient just you know Mike judge yes
yeah and only time I've ever used that
word I used it correctly I think you
know we turned 3 the other day and that
might be the first thing Yussef
prescient I don't I might be wrong a few
tablets so you need to sum it all up Ron
Livingston Will Sasso is in this too
Will Sasso historical like anything
will they doesn't work without the two
of them for you know the heart and soul
is is Ron Livingston but Will Sasso is
there's nothing he's in that isn't funny
he just makes everything funny and like
I said you know there was a girl on ER
Sobchak who's crazy good and then we
have Brian Regan the stand-up comedian
maybe the best stand-up comedian working
today by the way and that's saying no
that's saying a mouthful I mean it's
it's great 10:30 p.m. Eastern Time on
audience Network by DIRECTV AT&T u-verse
and DirecTV now Tuesday October 17 to
10:30 p.m. Eastern Time does so to sum
up watch Loudermilk and then brockman
this is truly the only new england
sports fan who talks well of Alex
Rodriguez no I don't believe that and
and and just as cool as a cucumber I'm
you and I can hang out any time but you
already you already knew that coming
we've done a very good good to see you
Peter Bobby projeto Peter Farrelly at
Farrelly Brothers on Twitter and check
out again Loudermilk Tuesday October
17th right here on audience at 10:30
p.m. Eastern Time
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy